- [Instructor] What we're going to do
in this video is start to think about
how we describe position in one dimension
as a function of time.
So we could say our position,
and we're gonna think about position
on the x-axis as a function of time.
And we could define it by some expression,
let's say, in this situation,
it is going to be our
time to the third power
minus three times our
time squared plus five.
And this is going to apply
for our time being non-negative
'cause the idea of negative time,
at least for now, is a bit strange.
So let's think about what this
right over here is describing.
And to help us do that,
we could set up a little bit of a table
to understand that depending
on what time we are,
let's say that time is in seconds,
what is going to be our
position along our x-axis?
So at time equals zero, x of
zero is just going to be five.
At time one, you're gonna have
one minus three plus five.
So that is going to be,
let's see, one minus
three is negative two,
plus five is going to be,
we're going to be at position three.
And then at time two, we are going to be
at eight minus 12 plus five,
so we're going to be at position one.
And then at time t equals three,
it's gonna be 27 minus 27 plus five,
we're gonna be back at five.
And so, this can at
least help us understand
what's going on for the
first three seconds.
So let me draw our positive x-axis.
So, say it looks something like that.
And this is x equals zero.
This is our x-axis.
X equals one, two, three, four, and five.
And now let's play out how this particle
that's being described is
moving along the x-axis.
So we're gonna start here,
and we're gonna go one, two, three.
Let's do it again.
We're going to go one, two, three,
the way I just moved
my mouse, if we assume
that I got the time roughly right,
is how that particle would move.
And we can graph this as well.
So for example, it would look like this.
We are starting at time t equals zero.
Our position, this is our
vertical axis, our y-axis,
but we're just saying
y is going to be equal
to our position along the x-axis.
So that's a little bit counterintuitive
because we're talking about our position
in the left-right dimension,
and here you're seeing it start off
in the vertical dimension,
but you see the same thing.
At time t equals one, our
position has gone down to three.
Then it goes down further.
At time equals two, our
position is down to one.
And then, we switch direction
and then over the next, if we
say that time is in seconds,
over the next second, we get back to five.
Now an interesting thing to think about
in the context of calculus is,
well, what is our velocity
at any point in time?
And velocity as you might remember,
is the derivative of position.
So let me write that down.
So we're gonna be thinking about velocity
as a function of time.
And you could view velocity
as the first derivative
of position with respect to time
which is just going to be equal to,
or we're gonna apply the power rule
and some derivative
properties multiple times.
If this is unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to review it.
But this is going to be three t squared
minus six t and then plus zero,
and we're gonna restrict
the domain as well for t
is greater than or equal to zero.
And then, we can plot that.
It would look like that.
Now let's see if this curve
makes intuitive sense.
We mentioned that one second, two seconds,
three seconds.
So we're starting moving to the left.
And the convention is if
you're moving to the left,
you have negative velocity,
and if you're moving to the right,
you have positive velocity.
And you can see here our velocity
immediately gets more and more negative
until we get to one second,
and then it stays negative
but it's getting less
and less negative until
we get to two seconds.
And at two seconds, our
velocity becomes positive.
And that makes sense,
because at two seconds
was when our velocity switched directions
to the rightward direction.
So, our velocity is getting
more and more negative,
less and less negative, and
then we switch directions
and we go just like that.
And we see it right over here.
Now one thing to keep in mind
when we're thinking about
velocity as a function of time
is that velocity and speed
are two different things.
Speed, speed, let me write it over here.
Speed is equal to, if you think about it
in one dimension, you could think about it
as the absolute value of your velocity
as a function of time or
your magnitude of velocity
as a function of time.
So in the beginning,
even though your velocity
is becoming more and more negative,
your speed is actually increasing.
Your speed is increasing to the left,
then your speed is
decreasing, you slow down,
and then your speed is increasing
as we go to the right.
And we'll do some worked examples
that work through that a little bit more.
Now the last concept we
will touch on in this video
is the idea of acceleration.
And acceleration you can view
as the rate of change of
velocity with respect to time.
So acceleration as a function of time
is just going to be the first derivative
of velocity with respect to time
which is equal to the second derivative
of position with respect to time.
It's just going to be the
derivative of this expression.
So once again, using the power rule here,
that's going to be six t.
And then using the power rule here,
minus six, and once again,
we will restrict the domain.
And we can graph that as well.
And we would see right over here,
this is y is equal to acceleration
as a function of time.
And you can see at time equals zero,
our acceleration is quite negative.
It is negative six.
And then it becomes less
and less and less negative.
And then, our acceleration actually
becomes positive at t equals one.
Now, does that makes sense?
Well, we're going one, two, three.
You might say, "Wait, we
didn't switch directions
"until we get to the second second."
But remember, after we
get to the first second,
our velocity in the negative direction
becomes less negative which means
that our acceleration is positive.
If that's a little confusing,
pause the video and
really think through that.
So, our acceleration is
negative, then positive,
and then positive continues.
And so, this is just to
give you an intuition.
In the next few videos, we'll
do several worked examples
that help us dive deeper into this idea
of studying motion and position,
into this idea of studying
motion in one dimension.